a celebration of the Studio's 100-year
animation Legacy Disney's wish is
finally in theaters and is a typically
Charming Love Letter to All Things
Disney want to know more about that
magical ending your wish is our
command wish begins with a traditional
storybook opening the narrator starts
the tale by telling the story of
magnifico the king and his Queen Amaya
who founded the kingdom of Rosas
magnifico studied Magic and was the one
person in Rosas who could grant wishes
so the people gave him their biggest
wish on their 18th birthday with the
understanding that they could be granted
by him at some point in the meantime
they forget the wish they gave to
magnifico Asha a 17-year-old girl is
interviewing to be the king's Apprentice
she seems to impress him until she
realizes that he won't Grant most of the
wishes including her 100-year-old
grandfathers because he judges them to
be too dangerous Asha tries to tell her
grandfather about what happened but
because it involves telling him his wish
he gets upset and tells her she's
excused from the family's dinner table
Asha runs out of the house and wishes
upon a star and the star comes down from
the sky and starts granting the animals
and plants wishes including that of
asha's goat Valentino I'm talking I am
talking who knew my voice would be this
low during this time magnifico sees the
bright light of the star and feels
threatened he calls a meeting to inform
the citizens that they should tell him
if they know anything about the light
and the citizens start questioning him
for the first time while this is
happening Asha sneaks up to the king's
study to take back her great grandf
father and mother's
wishes Asha heads home and gives her
grandfather's wish back but then
magnifico who has started using dark
magic appears he knows she's the one who
wished upon the star and he means to
make her pay she and her family Escape
in a rowboat but not before he crushes
asha's mother's wish making her feel
deeply sad magnifico calls another
meeting of the Kingdom where he
introduces his informant asha's only
friend who's over 18 Simon he has his
wish to be a knight granted but then
becomes the king Pawn Asha Valentino and
star return to the city from the rowboat
and join with her friends to take on the
king the queen appears and joins them
Asha leads magnifico away while the rest
of them go to get their wishes but when
magnifico finally catches up with Asha
it turns out it was Simon in Disguise
magnifico is still in the castle and
while Amaya and asha's friends managed
to gather the wishes with star's help
magnifico captures star and traps it in
his staff Asha runs to the castle to
stop this but magnifico disarms her with
magic Chi appeals to the people of Rosas
and as they make wishes they overcome
magnifico and he gets trapped in his own
staff star is freed and everyone can now
pursue their wishes as they see fit
Simon apologizes to Asha and Asha
becomes everyone's Fairy Godmother Asha
Wishing on a Star ended up inspiring
others and eventually the whole Kingdom
to rise up it's a compelling statement
about the power that one simple act can
have to convince others to take a stand
and help both themselves and
others magnifico seems to be be a
benevolent King so people give him their
wishes because one he promises to
safeguard them and two because of the
possibility that he'll grant them in
Rosas people don't wish upon Stars so in
order to have their wish come true
magnifico is their only option the
trouble is that once they give their
wishes to magnifico they forget all
about them this means if there's a
possibility that their wish could be
fulfilled through things like lessons or
hard work they can't pursue that because
they don't remember their wishes for
example asha's grandfather wants to
inspire people by playing the man
and through lessons and frequent
practice he could get good enough to
inspire people but because he
surrendered His Wish at 18 and can't
remember it he's done nothing to pursue
his wish since while magnifico tells the
people that giving up their wishes is a
great thing especially because he might
grant them at some point in reality it's
a tragedy people come here because they
know they can't make their own dreams
come true the journey is too hard it is
too unfair magnifico grants a lot of
wishes but he doesn't Grant everyone's
wish and that is by Design while there
are some acceptable wishes that slip
through the cracks because he simply
doesn't get to them there are many more
that he doesn't Grant because he judges
them to be too risky for instance they
could promote Anarchy or treason or they
could promote a smear campaign against
magnifico or they could do neither of
those things and be completely Innocent
but since magnifico doesn't know for
sure he doesn't Grant those wishes
asha's grandfather is again a perfect
example his desire to inspire people
with his mandolin is deemed too vague to
be granted so although it's a wish to
Asha it has the potential to be Sinister
to magnifico because he can imagine a
scenario where asha's grandfather's
music inspires people in negative ways
because magnifico has all the wishes and
no one else can even remember them he
and he alone has the power to judge each
person's wish granting only the ones he
finds innocuous they deserve more than I
decide what everyone deserves Asha is
perhaps the only person in Rosas who
would wish upon a star and it has
everything to do with her father her
father was deeply invested in the stars
and often took her to a tree out over
the water that allowed them to look at
the stars uninterrupted by the sights of
Rosas Asha learned from her father that
everyone is connected to the stars and
took that perspective to Heart
especially because he died when she was
12 making his observations all the more
precious to her she wishes upon the star
because of her father saying they're all
connected to the Stars she doesn't
expect anything to happen because of it
and is surprised when it does in fact
when she makes her wish which she states
in the song This wish she simply wants
everyone in Rosas to quote have
something more than this more
specifically she wants to give her
grandfather and mother's wishes back to
them so they can work on them themselves
she sees this as better than waiting for
them to be granted by magnifico
especially because he's already stated
that he will never Grant her
grandfather's wish your wish will never
be granted when Asha States her wish the
star she wishes on comes down to earth
to be by her side as she tries to write
the wrongs of magnifico however it
doesn't Grant asha's wish Jennifer Le
the co-writer of wish told Rotten
Tomatoes star really is all those things
that Disney gives us hope possibility
Wonder joy that doesn't tell you the
answers it's just there for you when you
need it so star isn't there to make
asha's dream come true it's there
instead to offer hope and back her up
when she needs it this can be seen by
the way star accompanies Asha when she
breaks into magnifico's study and takes
back her grandfather's wish it helps
them to get out of the locked elevator
to the castle for example by using its
magic to unlock the door but Asha has to
do the lifting of taking her
grandfather's wish herself that said
there are times when Star can make
wishes come true it does this for many
of the animals and plants in the forest
sprinkling them with stard dust so they
can talk and therefore granting their
wishes star also makes the wishes float
out of the castle so the people can
reclaim them so star does have the
ability to help to some
extent in the end Asha through her
kindness and selflessness has managed to
free the whole Kingdom from the tyranny
of magnifico while Amaya the queen has
become the ruler of the Kingdom Asha is
Anointed The Kingdom's Fairy Godmother
by star who gives her a wand and robes
in a ceremony that is very much like
that in Cinderella when Cinderella gets
her gown for the ball alsa objects to
the new role which is exactly why she'll
be good at it according to her friends
but granting wishes exactly as a fairy
godmother would make it seem like she's
pretty much replacing magnifico given he
was doing the same thing Asha promises
to be just about it and that seems to be
enough for the people of Rosas but it's
hard not to wonder if Asha will stick to
that sentiment after after all she's
only 17 she has a lot of Life to Live
and the power to grant wishes has the
power to corrupt her just like it did
magnifico Ariana debose is excited to be
part of wish voicing Asha she's a
longtime Disney fan so to come to the
film that is being put out as part of
Disney's 100th is a special honor when
asked what audiences can take away from
the film de bose told the Nerds of color
in this particular film to watch this
young girl of color with braids and
freckles and unlikely leader step into
her power it doesn't mean that she's not
afraid she is and it doesn't mean that
she doesn't make mistakes she does but
to see how one person can step up to the
plate and say I'm not really sure how
I'm going to get my way through but I'm
going to get through Chris Pine like
debose was tickled to be part of wish
voicing magnifico he was especially
thrilled to be voicing the villain
telling Kim hul there's humor to it the
guy's a buffoon I think I like playing
characters that think they're really
really cool and simply aren't when you
get underneath the hood it's always fun
to play those guys even his Hero song
this is the thanks I get is the most
revealing song about his deep
insecurities about being loved Pine also
had many complimentary things to say
about his co-star and the chemistry they
shared Pine told today's Esquire working
with Ariana was an absolute Delight
she's not only an incredibly talented
performer but also a wonderful person
our chemistry on set translated
seamlessly onto the screen and I'm
grateful for the
experience Jennifer Lee has been part of
some of the greatest animated films of
the last 15 years including Frozen which
she co-direct Ed she also co-wrote the
screenplay for wish and spoke about Asha
to Rotten Tomatoes saying we were
talking about Asha and knowing we wanted
that moment as a teenager where you're
living your life everything's fine and
then all of a sudden you're like hey
that's not right and I always say it's a
very generous time teenagers are the
ones who want to make the world better
for others we give them a bad rep
sometimes that they're selfish and I'm
like they're the ones who can see a
better world Peter Delco a veteran
producer of Disney animated films has a
lot to say about the villain telling
comic book
Disney villains have evolved over time
and some villains are revealed but
there's something delicious about
knowing that someone's the villain from
the beginning what makes this one unique
is he's also charming and charismatic
and you actually watch him evolve as
more pressure is put on
[Music]
him